there's no wrong decision about when you
get uncomfortable it's really a matter
of personal preference
um the building stage the most
interesting the most I think vulnerable
business stage is scaling up after the
initial investment and making the right
decisions
so that the first few years where you
really scale up matter and set the base
for the future welcome to 20 minute
leaders just sit back relax and learn
from the leaders of today it's a journey
each one is different unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures Jay Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today I have the pleasure and honor of
speaking with Amo sarev the executive
vice president of engineering and
general manager at capitolis Amos is a
highly experienced engineering executive
who has been at the Forefront of
Technology Innovation for decades prior
to joining capitolis he served as the
vice president of research and
development at law Geeks a company
focused on AI in the legal industry with
more than 20 years of expertise he
brings deep expertise in data
engineering research and development and
technology spearheading these efforts at
leading technology in data companies
such as Global e hexatier siren and
Skybox security almost holds a
Bachelor's of science to the Green
Electrical and electronic engineering
from the technion Israel Institute of
Technology and a master of science
degree in electrical and electronic
engineering from Tel Aviv University
such an awesome episode I hope you
enjoyed
I can only imagine how busy you are so
really thank you for taking the time and
Amos I I don't even know how to start
listing off the incredible
things you've done today you're
Executive Vice President of engineering
and GM of Israel of capitolis but you
know starting all the way from from
Converse in the 90s to then a checkpoint
as r d group manager Skybox security
vice president research and development
siren as vice president Richard the list
goes on and on and on and on you're
obviously a really a phenomenal
technology leader and that's exactly
what I want to talk to you about today
what does it mean to be a technology
leader to lead research and development
across the variety of organizations in
different sectors and and really why do
you enjoy it so much because only
somebody who enjoys it so much can do it
the way that you're doing it so again
Amos thank you very much for being here
so let me start from the last decade or
so where I've been joining companies for
strong day
um and taking them from the POC stage
where they got the initial
large Investments have it after having
proven uh the idea and then taking them
to scale
and I think this is the most interesting
part of being a technology leader
bringing to the table your capabilities
as a leader and with all of what you
know how to do as an engineer but really
being part of the executive team and
shaping the company
and getting to have control of how the
company shapes up what is that we do
with the first customers
how technology comes into play but not
necessarily just doing technology
and eventually
each time again starting from a very
small team that wrote the POC and then
getting it to a larger team that you
shape and kind of key players for and
get them to have the culture and
eventually scale with them where most of
what you do is just make sure that
everything is going the right direction
but not really managing the detail
interesting that's what I enjoy the kick
I get is from starting all over again
with a small team
well in later years I've moved away from
security and I'm always looking for
companies that are disruptors in the
field that they're in that have a very
new idea of something that has always
been done differently right right I mean
you're looking at that legal and now
you're looking at Capital markets so
obviously quite a big shift but I want
to you know you you're mentioning these
companies are have raised the series a
you know a lot of companies rate series
especially in the last decade so you
kind of have a difficult Choice ahead of
you right every three years or so as
you're transitioning between these
companies making that that big impact
you have to decide yourself you know
which company you're betting on which
team you're looking to join so what what
goes into the decision making process
for Amos over these last 20 years as to
how are you choosing which team to spend
your time with
um it has to be an Innovative thing but
that is very
thoughtful of what they're doing so that
thought through all of the details of
what they're trying to solve for
it has to be a team of veterans who
already have seen failures in the past
and survive them they learn from them
has to be closely lit team that is not
just a bunch of individuals but everyone
tells the same story
it has to have a very good lineup of
investors who are deeply involved in
what we're doing
and this is all part of the decision
making book for the team that's
considering me and for me considering
the team
interesting that that is it almost
sounds like a very very good investment
strategy what you're outlining here and
then kind of your time is probably the
most important investment you can make
right
yeah I think I think it is uh and I
think that every time the other company
it's not for the purpose of leaving
after three years I was drawn for the
long term
um this is the only way I think to look
at joining any team that you spend most
of your time in
and yes definitely like an investment
decision
so go back a little bit to sort of this
underlying pattern of joining a team
that successfully built an interesting
POC is ready to now scale this you found
that this is sort of your your sweet
spot why you know what what is it about
this process that excites you so much
because it could be leading you know you
could join a company as as VPR D that is
much larger leading hundreds of people
in a mature phase very different type of
work what is it about sort of the
scaling nature that really gets you
excited it sounds also you're you're
highly involved with the executive team
with sort of these strategic
decision-making processes foreign
I think
there's no
um
wrong decision about when you get
uncomfortable it's really a matter of
personal preference
um the building stage the most
interesting the most I think vulnerable
business stage is scaling up after the
initial investment and making the right
decisions
so that the first few years where you
really scale up matter and set the base
for the future
well that's a high stake game so you
need to be all in you need to really
really understand the business case and
all the details and what's one thing for
me is every time I enter a company
where there's a new domain it's yet
another challenge to learn and
specifically in capitalists where I had
I don't even know how to balance my own
checkbook which was my first answer to
Gil when he called me amazing
is uh and by the way I'll leave his
answer for your next question
um I think it's it's about understanding
what makes that team tick and how you
really set the foundation
and since the stakes are high it's
really more interestingly I know there's
a lot of interest in people my friends
who are on the other teams it's a whole
new profession called different
profession learning than the provision
that I'm holding I feel that this is one
Street's fault it requires a lot of
energy from your end because you have to
con you're basically an entrepreneur
yourself right you're you're an
entrepreneur you're a technology
entrepreneur that is partnering with
with other entrepreneurs at some point
along their journey and making a big
impact to this I guess that also
requires quite a bit of energy from your
end as well yeah and it also requires
you to change the digital investor
initially when you join the small team
you kind of do everything you call the
right hand you do all the interviews you
make sure that
um
the kitchen is stacked correctly with
all the figures have to be anything for
and eventually the team rolls then you
look at how the team is steals then the
all the leaders and the CEOs
get them from inside should you look for
people who are outside no how do you
spell the technology so in a very short
final time you get to do a lot of
different things in the domination of
the company
so it's fought into tutorial but it's
not from the initial stage of thinking
of the original idea it's right
the opportunity to look at the idea and
enter the scene when there's kind of a
proof that it works sure and then
cartoon that search
sure and I mean I think that at the end
you know the there's a few phases
obviously to startups one phase is you
know being the Visionary under okay we
have this great Market great opportunity
this blue ocean that we're about to
tackle and then there's okay let's
create sort of this technological POC to
show a validation but then you come in
and say okay is this actually have room
to be a stable technology that will
persist long term Way Beyond the POC and
that's sort of where you come in and uh
and and that has to get validated just
as the idea needs to get validated it's
just a different sort of validation
right yeah
incredible tell me a little bit about
capitolis at Capital markets what what
got you into what what God hooked you
hooked onto this company almost three
years ago
soles
um is trying to solve inefficiencies in
the couple of markets
um when you look at the way Regulators
word said specifically since 2008
um
it's both a good thing since more
regulation actually makes the banking
system safer
but it also limits the capacity well how
Banks can operate because eventually it
puts the limits on collateral that's
being put against risks that are being
taken
so and
this is a real issue because eventually
it affects everything it affects the
price of services developed by the Banks
it can be services vended to other Banks
or other on financial institutions but
it can also be to the person buying a
pension fund
and eventually
this needs to be solved in a way that is
a very clear and very clean but also
very efficient and we do this in two
ways
um one is we look at the portfolio that
each of the banks have so future
investments in foreign exchange
and then we offer ways in which banks
can change their way the portfolio is on
set up so it's more efficient and less
volatile it should be put against it
and this is a networking game because
each of these portfolios actually
portrays connections between the banks
and other banks that are involved
um in addition we also look for other
inefficiencies where we need to
to collect
institutions that are liquid and looking
for Investments with institutions that
need this liquidity in order to to work
outside of their own books in which case
we actually
helpful Banks be more of a platform when
they can operate their own Financial
structures and we get investment daily
by which we also freedom of the needs to
have the money invested written all
purpose
um
both of these games are networking games
they involve a lot of interaction with
the players it's not a game often a lot
of players but it's very involved
foreign
interest in this was
that it is very interesting for me to
find out how technology comes into play
into this because it's not
a large-scale operation it's a very
delicate a lot of detail operation
and it's also
you don't actually
find out what the product is until you
are actually deeply involved in actually
running the products so you need to
start playing with the players
you need to understand what they need
and then the need changes and then the
clergy needs to keep up with this in a
way that eventually you actually develop
a scalable platform which is a really
really hard puzzle to solve
you have to continuously evolve to this
now you mentioned that when you when you
first spoke to Gil it it was a kind of a
foreign world to you
yeah it wasn't I asked him why me
okay and he said
um
I have a lot of Bankers who are very
proficient at what they do but I need a
technologist to join the team what
technology is the main thing and it's
not about banking
and initially when I joined the company
it was such a vast
um lack of knowledge that I spent a lot
of my time talking to the people who are
experienced in banking just trying out
what it is that makes this business
stick
until eventually again told me that
I'm never going to be able to play in
the field and this is not actually the
game you should be playing and you know
that's what I'm doing and then standing
North for me to make sure that
What I Hear makes sense and it's enough
for me to understand what technology
needs to be created
and this dropped depending for me
because
my role in this team
is to really bring to the table
my strategic views on what I should be
doing my team should be doing in order
to be able to scale and also play the
game which is Ever Changing
and be able to take part in making
strategic decisions about the company
without needing to be the expert in the
banking
interesting wow so so looking back at
and was that sort of a similar
experience to what you had in legal and
previously in cyber sort is this is this
like a pattern as you transition into
new markets that you're able to balance
the technology
execution and strength with imbalance
with your understanding of the market
and sort of the complexity of the idea
because all the companies that you've
worked with they've all been very you
know provided very complicated Theses
around their the market that they're in
it's not a simple product to understand
by no means
yes but I think if you look at security
and it's this is a very personal ideal
way of looking at it but
I think that when you look at security
usually
you have a good idea of what you want to
achieve
it creates a product that you need to
educate the market to use
and Venture the technology drives again
and you're constantly thinking about the
next step where the market isn't even
thinking about it hmm in contrast when
you look at what we do at capitalis
technology needs to be the game changer
but it by no means strives again the
game is played by rules of the banker
system
and you need to be novel in the way you
play with these rules and introduce
technology into it to make this a
scalable very good solution
so it's very very different and I was
used to
always being head of the park by
installing technology and run the
product and
having the next step ahead and talking
to customers and just educating them on
the right new ideas that we had
in this industry
those parts part of it is that but it's
not the technology novelty that's
driving it it's a combination of the
financial structuring novelty the
multidisciplinary nature of it backed by
technology that actually makes them
state scale
that's interesting
so transitioning a little bit to and
obviously I know that you're very very
humble and modest it'll be hard for me
to get this out of you but you know if
you're looking at technology leadership
and what's worked for you and what makes
you a successful VPR indeed across the
different organizations that you've been
with and it sounds that the thing the
way that you're speaking about your
experiences it resonates a lot with a
very mature understanding and a lot of
past experiences even just the way that
you're describing what you're looking
for in a company that you're joining
whether it's sort of this veteran team
that has gone through challenges and
overcame them or survived them and the
the involvement of the investors so so
sort of what makes you a successful
technology leader in the day today if
you think about sort of these groups
that you're building from the ground up
what makes you successful there
I think
if I need to narrow it down to one thing
it's being able to identify the correct
people and get a good team that scares
and is that is that it generalized
across the different organizations the
same way or do different people fit
better into different organizations in
your from your perspective
there are commonalities I think that the
good team is the team that
um is mainly built from people or
critical thinkers
and
actually understand that whatever is
stopping in is just them
there's nothing there's no feeling
um and my thought in this is
finding out how the team should be
constructed and who the
what parts the people in the team should
be playing
and eventually
the culture is created that is different
between continues because I think the
business affects the people who like to
be part of this business and eventually
there's a different culture to each but
I think the common thing between all of
the teams the successful things that
I've been fortunate to have to build
is dots eventually my role is just
navigating
and people do their own thing and
eventually within this chaos I'm able to
just read the big picture and be able to
help them navigate through whatever it
is that they're doing and this is
scale
eventually my idea of success is that
I love that so sort of what about
technology it's not about it's not about
yeah I'm involved in architecture yeah I
have my say in
what tools we should be choosing but
this is these are just pet products it's
really the people I love it so your your
kpi is how do I make myself
a little bit less relevant in different
areas where this organ this family that
I'm building this organization that I'm
building from the ground up both
culturally professionally socially sort
of operates as a functional unit that is
able to be self-sustaining uh where and
and I love that I just love that um that
that mindset and and honestly almost I
have to say that I've been doing this
for a long time this podcast I've spoken
to him over 900 people and and you're
the the the the true
um
authentic way of being and how you enjoy
what you do and how intentionally you
are about why you're doing this and why
you're joining these companies and and
how fulfillment and how much fulfillment
you get from building these great teams
and watching them scale
um that intentionality is very inspiring
so I really want to thank you for that
as well as for for the time I know
you're very busy so again thank you for
joining me here and I I highly
appreciate it best of luck with with
capitolus and and and everything else
thank you very much forever thank you
[Music]